αυτό δεν εφάνηκε να έχει την επίδραση που θα είχε άλλες εποχές έτσι είτε στες
τημές είτε ότι δήποτε ευκή κάνει τμες πάνω αλλά όι στον βαθμό που θα νεμέν
κάποιος ότι το αανεβούν ήταν αμενόμενο λόγο και της ανη υχίας τατος οτα ασφαλές τατα
ετι μές ευκειήκα πάω απλά αφαίνεται ότι υπάρχει παρι περισσότερι παραγωγή πετρελέε ου παραδιμός χάρη
από ότι υπήρχε προηγούμενης νατελιώδου επίησης υπάρχει και κουράκαι μια κούρασ του κόσμος εδέθκιας μορφής
έγινε καθημερινότητα στη μέση ανα τολίη των το πράμα που βλέπουμε τον τελευταίο χρόνο δε
έγινε οι καθημερινότης μέσεις ανατολής άρά οι επίδραση ταν μπορεί λιγοτε τα εξτερνάλιτης τα λέγομενα
που λέμε στον πολεμοντά ανιντέτον σίγουενσες οι επιδράσεις που δεν τς αναμένεις που τέλος πάντοντις
αναμένεις αλλά δε εν απεφτές δε δεν έχουμε θκες επιδράσς αυτή τη στιγμή που να
ντόσο μεγάλες που να πηρεάζουν τους πάντες όμως έχουμε το σενάριο του περιφερειακού ις περιφερεακής
πληος σύραξης διότι όταν του λέε ο εράν θα κλείσωτα τα στενά του ορμος από
το οποίο περνά το ένάμπετον του πετρελέου φυσικά να πούμε εεδώ διότι το έναμπετον του
πετρελέου αλλά το περιμεγαλύτερο μέρος πάι στην κίνα πο ουτου τ συγκεκριμένη όδευση αναθρθάντω επνα
επηρεάσει τόσον την αεκιώθω ότι εδιαφέρει και ναν παραπάνω δώρα τού τη συζητησή παράθα τηραμέρικίτην
ευρώπι όμως τα σενάρια εμένι εχούθις ανέχουμε περιφερειακής σύνραξη ι εμπλοκή πλήρην των αμερικάν σετου
διαδικασία θα έχουμε